nearly a year after a woman went missing
in las vegas stephanie sue hickman
hasn't been heard from since july of
last year her daughter believes she
could be in danger sasha loftis joining
us now in studio with more on her story
brian and denise this woman's
disappearance has been a mystery her
whole family has been trying to solve
for the better part of a year now
they're reaching out hoping someone here
in the valley knows something
just the strongest woman that i know
harmony reed describes everything she
loves about her mom i don't want her to
be in any danger i don't want her to get
in trouble stephanie sue hickman hasn't
been heard from since july of last year
she's from washington but harmony says
the 45 year old came here to las vegas
in 2021 then disappeared it's very
unlike my mom for her not to reach out
at least every few months harmony says
police told her stephanie resurfaced
about a month ago when she was cited for
trespassing at a business here at
charleston and nellis
she also tells us she got a cryptic
phone call from an unknown number
recently and says the person on the
other line sounded like her mom but
there's no way to know for sure there
for a while i just felt like i was in
this
like this abyss where
i didn't i had no idea what i could do
for her she's working with police but
hopes the community can come together to
get answers even faster that's kind of
where i turn to social media like hey
like help me bring my mom home harmony
hopes anyone out there who may know
something can come forward so she can
finally have her family back together i
don't want her to feel like we've given
up on her
harmony says her mom was also diagnosed
with bipolar disorder which puts her at
a higher risk without help if you have
any information you are asked to call
metro's missing persons detail at this
number here 702-828-9207